it's difficult to know much for certain
about the Chinese philosopher lao-tzu
even his name can be a little confusing
it's also sometimes translated as loud
CEO loud say loud sue is said to have
been a record keeper in the court of the
central Chinese Zhu dynasty in the 6th
century BC and an older contemporary of
Confucius he may also have been entirely
mythical much like Homer in Western
culture loud sue said to have tired of
life in a zoo court as it grew
increasingly morally corrupt so he left
and rode on a water buffalo to the
western border of the Chinese Empire
although he was dressed as a farmer the
border official recognized him and asked
him to write down his wisdom according
to this legend what loud sue wrote
became the sacred texts known as the Tao
Te Ching after writing this piece loud
sue is said to have crossed the border
and disappeared from history perhaps to
become a hermit in reality the Tao Te
Ching is likely to be the compilation of
the works of many authors over time but
stories about Lao Tzu in the Tao Te
Ching itself passed down through
different Chinese philosophical schools
for over 2,000 years
Lao Tzu was the leading figure in a
spiritual practice we now known as
Taoism which has more than 2,000 years
old and still popular today there are at
least 20 million Daoists and perhaps
even half a billion living around the
world now especially in China in Taiwan
they practice meditation chant
scriptures and worship a variety of gods
and goddesses and temples Taoist also
make pilgrimages to five sacred
mountains in eastern China in order to
pray at the temples and absorb spiritual
energy from these holy places which are
believed to be governed by immortals
Taoism is deeply intertwined with other
branches of thought like Confucianism
and Buddhism there is a story about the
three great Asian spiritual leaders loud
sue Confucius and Buddha all were meant
to have tasted vinegar
Confucius found it sour much like he
found the world full of degenerate
people and Buddha found it bitter much
like he found the world to be full of
suffering but Lao Tzu found the world
sweet this is telling because loud Sue's
philosophy tends to look at the apparent
discord in the world and see an
underlying harmony guided by something
called the dowel the
or teaching which describes the dowel is
somewhat like the Bible it gives
instructions often vague and generally
open to multiple interpretations on how
to live a good life it discusses the DAO
as the way of the world which is also
the path to virtue happiness and harmony
the way isn't an inherently confusing or
difficult thing but in order to follow
the DAO we need to go beyond simply
reading and thinking about it instead we
must learn flowing or effortless action
it's a sort of purposeful acceptance of
the way of the DAO and living in harmony
with it this might seem lofty and
bizarre but most of loud sooo
suggestions are actually very simple
first we ought to make more time for
stillness to the mind that is still
doubts who said the whole universe
surrenders we need to let go of our
schedules worries and complex thoughts
for a while and simply experience the
world we spent so much time rushing from
one place to the next in life but loud
sue reminds us nature does not hurry yet
everything is accomplished it's
particularly important that we remember
certain things grieving growing wiser
developing a new relationship only
happen on their own schedule like the
changing of leaves in the autumn or the
blossoming of the bulbs we planted
months ago when we're still inpatient we
also need to be open the usefulness of a
pot comes from its emptiness loud sue
said empty yourself of everything let
your mind become still if we're too busy
too preoccupied with anxiety or ambition
we will miss a thousand moments of human
experience that are our natural
inheritance need to be awake to the
sounds of the birds in the morning the
way other people look when they're
laughing
the feeling of wind against our face
these experiences reconnect us to parts
of ourselves this is another key point
of loud Sue's writing we need to be in
touch with our real deep ourselves we
spend a great deal of time worrying
about who we ought to become but we
should instead take time to be who we
already are at heart
we might rediscover a generous impulse
or a playful side we'd forgotten or
simply an old affection for long walks
our ego is often in the way of our true
self which must be found by being
receptive to the outside world rather
than focusing on some critical to
ambitious internal image when I let go
of Who I am
Lao Tzu wrote I become what I might be
nature is particularly useful for
helping us to find ourselves loud sue
liked to come
different parts of nature to different
virtues he said the best people are like
water which benefits all things and does
not compete with them it stays in lowly
places that others reject that is why
it's so similar to the dowel each part
of nature can remind us of a quality we
admire and should cultivate ourselves
the strength of the mountains the
resilience of trees the cheerfulness of
flowers of course there are issues that
must be addressed by action and there
are times for ambition yet loud Sue's
work is important for Taoist and non
Taoist alike especially in a modern
world distracted by technology and
focused on what seemed to be constant
sudden and severe changes his words
serve as a reminder of the importance of
stillness openness and discovering
buried yet central parts of ourselves
you